Today is day,
what are the shutdown?
26th that would just be so 800,000 American workers that work for the government
are not getting paid.
So there are a month out many of these people paycheck to paycheck.
They don't have medical necessities,
they don't have food.
People that are happening to our rationale off their,
their,
their insulin.
If they're diabetic.
I mean I'm hearing these horror horror stories,
the lines at the airport or around the fucking block.
It's,
it's chaos.
And it seems like there's no end in sight.
And it seems like Trump is just content to,
to sell,
hold this position.
I think both sides are content to older position.
That seems fucking crazy to me.
It is crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
If you think about it.
And it's not just 800,000,
I don't know the exact numbers,
but think about all the,
the contractors,
I think when all the government contractors,
right,
right.
You know,
if I can stay and I don't think they're getting paid.
Um,
and so this has,
and,
and you know,
the administration has admitted that,
look,
we initially underestimated the impact of,
of a long term term shutdown.
And so they understand that.
And the Democrats,
you know,
talk about it every minute about how this is a terrible crisis.
And so you would think that if both sides feel that way,
uh,
then get something done and looked at the Democrats that Dave approved in the
past,
recent past,
many of these Democrats voted for fencing barriers,
whatever you want to call it.
Yeah.
But we're lost in semantics and because the president's so hated by this,
you know,
this,
or this group that,
you know,
they've seized on this term wall.
If he had started his campaign by saying we need to improve our border security
and,
uh,
find fixes to an immigration system that is both fair and secure and efficient.
If he had gone with that,
it's a word he bumper sticker.
But if he had gone with that and we'd have a different conversation right now,
we would,
but maybe would have a different president as well.
Yeah.
That's okay.
That's a good point.
You know,
there's something about that build that wall that's like the dopes.
We're like,
Whoa,
I get it,
John.
It's a wall.
Still simple.
Build a wall.
Oh yeah.
Lucker castle.
Build a wall.
It seems so,
uh,
it's,
it's such a visual now.
You're right.
That's,
and that's,
you know,
that's where I miss out.
I'm not,
yeah,
I'm way off on the,
in terms of being clever about politics,
but I think that,
well,
how to rope in rubes.
Yeah,
yeah.
I should,
I should get better at that.
That seems like,
but he's got that down.
Boy.
I didn't even know the people that voted for him.
The people that are like real magna supporters.
I didn't even know the existed in the numbers.
They exist.
It's like he uncovered a rock.
Like you flipped a rock over and there was an ant colony of rubes in there.
And just the sheer numbers,
it's like,
whoa.
The,
and it's a mixed bag,
right?
It's a mixed bag.
You've got a lot of people very,
you know,
cause it's,
I,
I don't buy the idea that it's all just a bunch of,
you know,
uh,
crackers are a bunch of idiots.
No,
there's a,
it's a,
it's a real range of people.
There's,
there's that group of people that were just tired of being told they're idiots
and they came out in force.
Now you can't tell,
you can't talk down to people.
This is for the Democrats can't keep talking down to people and expect at some
point they're not going to punch in the nose.
Right.
Well,
there's still now,
and there's still a,
there,
there was some congressmen recently that was talking about all the people that
supported Trump and he was talking about them all being losers and alcoholics
and illiterate.
And I'm like,
man,
you're talking about half the country.
Right?
And no lesson learned,
right?
No,
absolutely.
No self awareness.
And,
uh,
and that's,
you know,
that's the story of,
of,
you know,
every election I think going forward is,
you've,
you,
you've got the urban centers and you've got everybody else and everybody else
feels as if they are getting kicked in the ass.
And so I,
but,
but yeah,
I at the same time,
you think what we should be able to do better,
right?
We should,
I again,
certain policies that they've got great,
but every day another,
you know,
tweet that seems a little dysfunctional every day,
some misstep every day,
some self inflicted wound,
um,
shouldn't happen.
Not in a country this size,
not,
not where we've got this much talent and skill and capability.
So I don't know what 2020 is going to bring,
but it's,
we got to wear it for a hell of a ride between um,
you know,
look at all the shit that's happening.
Yeah.
This seems like it might be one of the bigger moves on the chessboard though.
This government shutdown,
like how this gets resolved one way or another and who comes out,
at least the,
the visual is the optics are that they're the winner.
Yeah.
That's,
it seems very critical because if the Democrats win and somehow or another he
abandons his idea for a wall,
abandons the billions of dollars that he's been asking for for this wall that
gives them momentum.
We kicked his ass with that wall and we're going to kick his ass and 2020 what
they're thinking that is,
that is exactly what they're discussing in the war room when Nancy Pelosi keeps
them all in lockstep and she's done a good job so far of keeping the dams in
line.
Um,
and that's why they wanted her back in.
At least the old guard wanted him back in because that's what she does.
Well,
aside from fundraising,
so I,
you know,
I have a feeling that,
look,
he's asking for whatever,
five point $7 billion in the scheme of things.
That's a drop in the bucket and Schumer and Pelosi and a wide variety of other
people,
including the previous president of all voted in the past for additional funding
for border security,
including fencing and barriers.
But they are,
they're not going to budge off of this.
So what the hell does that mean?
Does that mean he's,
he's being pushed into a corner where he has no option but to declare a national
emergency and use funds elsewhere so that he can say,
I finally got it done and looked at dams,
didn't do anything.
Uh,
who knows?
But you're,
I think you're absolutely right.
Whoever's perceived as the winner out of this ridiculous situation,
uh,
yeah,
they're going to beat that drum all the way to 2020.